you did a thing which I thought was
really cool which is there's a lot of
people out there young people 17 18
years old who are not going to have
their prom so people have been posting
prom photos and you put up your yearbook
photo
I'm not prom photos but your yearbook
photo just sort of let people know hey
we're with you in spirit you're not
gonna get to have your prom so here's my
yearbook photo you put this thing up and
I have to talk to you about it I love
everything first fo not that small the
birth of the beard
yeah the birth of the beard but also the
head is cold I have a unique point of
view
yeah no dates yeah yeah now I uh what's
funny is the kids don't even know this
but that was the picture that ran in our
freshman year Facebook before Facebook
was like a democracy democracy
destroying thing it was a literal book
that had pictures of all of the incoming
freshmen and that's what I advertised to
new kids just it's very it's very Ross
on friends well yours is Ross on friends
I don't know I am going to show you mine
now
yeah II I was such a nice little girl
conditioner the author the furthering
the feathering in the hair I was a I was
a yes thank you thank you very much I
was very very proud of that and I did a
good job